this week on the true jordi podcast it's
the world's strongest man and first
person
ever to deadlift 500 kilograms
eddie hall just 24 hours after his arch
rival the mountain thor
pulled 501 kilograms in a controversial
claim
for a world record and now the two
giants have announced that they will
settle this once and for all
in the ring i personally think this
shouldn't be classed as a world record
everyone can now set world records at
the home gym and record it and where do
you draw the line i witnessed four's dad
weighing the plates we all know how easy
it is to sort of rig these things up now
i'm not saying that happened but what i
am saying is
the speculation is there this rivalry
between you two
it's becoming the biggest thing i've
ever have in a strong man he's been
around my house you know we've had
parties at my house in the past i used
to i used to really like before we were
great friends
he became a bit of a monster everything
had to be his way he accused me of being
a cheat
at will strongest man 2017 and he threw
all these accusations out there that the
referees were corrupt the events were
changed in my favor
so much [__] that four came out with
and put this black cloud around my will
strongest man win
i trained my whole life for this one
moment and this guy
tried to take it away from me because he
couldn't take being beat by a better man
the loser doesn't get a silver medal and
stands a little bit below each other on
a podium he's on the floor
potentially and i think with how big you
guys are it stands to reason that one of
yours is getting trimmed
where i'm from we don't deal with things
with words you know straight away it's
fists up let's sort this out like men
and that that's how i've been brought up
i'm gonna leave no stone unturned i'm
gonna do
everything in my power to make sure i go
in that range and [__] ridicule this
prick
if i'm confident in my head i'm going to
beat you beat the [__] out of you
then you should [__] run forget the
deadlift forget after you
you called me a cheat and i'm going to
correct that by knocking you the
[__] out this week on the true
geordie podcast is one of the strongest
human beings
ever former world strongest man 2017
eddie hall how are you doing me
hey buddy oh yeah i'm doing good brian
how about you mate
i'm [__] spot on me i'm uh delighted
to have you on because you are currently
one of the most talked about people in
the world again
uh you're you're old for thor just
pulled
501 and told the world the massive news
that i knew before most people that you
and him
are getting in the ring this is insane
yeah um big deal let's just take apart
this 501 for a start because
the whole world is calling this a new
world record it's all over twitter
the mountains trending and there
is amongst uh the experts a bit of
debate
about this is whether or not this is a
world record you hold
the world record what do you think um
well well firstly i want to say well
done to four for pulling 501 kilo
regardless of
where it was done and how it was done i
know what that takes
so from me to you for just want to say
well done regardless of any of the bad
negativity around the situation sorry to
interrupt you how did it feel watching
that goal because it was impressive
oh yeah yeah definitely you know i
watched it and i did the 465 and i was
like
i i actually did a comparison video very
quickly
of my 65 465 compared to his and mine
was a little bit faster
um and then as soon as you pulled the
501 i did another comparison video and
mine was a little bit faster so i i
guess it was just like a little bit of
self-satisfaction for myself really
um but yeah a hell of a lift you know
you can't deny that four
is a monster he's six foot nine is it
he's a genetic freak you know he's
destined to pull these kind of weights
you can never take that away from a guy
like that
i respect that mate but like i said
earlier this there's so much debate
going on
in the strongman world about the
legitimacy because for those who don't
know
these world records are usually done in
competition
now i take the point that thor can't be
in competition right now
but he's had four years since you did
that world record where he hasn't done
it in a competition
and now when it's impossible he's done
it in his own gym
and people are calling it a gym lift
that can you kind of break down
where you see this as a difference
between yours and his potentially if you
do
yeah well i mean four was planned i mean
to be fair to four he did plan to pull
the 501 kilo in bahrain i think i
believe it was
in april uh the middle of april um and i
had no qualms with that you know i was
happy i was actually going to attend and
actually commentate that competition and
i didn't have it i didn't have a
word to say about it and then four
announced um that he was doing this 501
kilo deadlift
you know in his home gym which
automatically just just sparked
a big question mark for me put you know
and i always i always look at other
sports as well you know you look at the
olympics you look at all the olympians
training and
you know obviously the olympics is
cancelled and
do you see usain bolt or or usain bolt's
second man doing
runs on his track and getting his mate
to referee and saying it's a world
record
or do you for instance there was a
person who ran
a marathon in under two hours and it got
loads of
um sort of as you say you went trending
it went nuts but nobody said world
record because it wasn't done in a
proper marathon
and i believe this is the same
circumstances if you want to break
a world record then you've got to do it
in a competition now
there are different kinds of world
records there are caught there of course
you know i mean i've done many world
records in loads of circumstances but i
would class these as
almost circus hacks you know i've done
deadly i did a deadlift in a bookstore
once with with
and i lifted books but and everyone's
sort of bringing that up
um but i will happily say if you want to
diminish that world record and say it's
bs i'd be happy for
i'd be happy for that world record to go
back to tom mcgee who pulled it back in
will's strongest man
back in whenever but uh where's the
where'd you draw the line there because
you know i lifted i lifted 536 kilowatt
books
now as far as i'm aware you cannot get
calibrated boots
and it's an 18-inch deadlift it's a
circus act it's the deformed lift from
the 500
from the from the normal deadlift and as
far as i'm aware
uh when tom mcgee did the world record
silver deadlift in the will strongest
man
you can't get calibrated cheese as well
so
you know we lifted cheese blocks so
there are some things that can be done
outside competition
and there's some things that can't and
another example would be
you know lauren chali has done farmers
walk world records on guinness guinness
book of world records
firstly let's just be very clear here
guinness book of world records do not
sanction any world records all they do
is report on them
so and get a guinness book of world
records is a business
that that makes makes money off
showcasing these ridiculous things you
know they they say how many body
piercings do people have and stuff like
that and
how far can a cowboy spit so to say
because it's a guinness book of world
records recognize it doesn't make it
legit
and you know even by lawrence's uh
farmers walkers car walk even
every farmers walks different every car
walks different
but my main argument is here a
calibrated bar
and calibrated plate and the settings it
is done in
in a competition they can't be that
cannot be a circus act
it just can't be we spent years and
years and years
finding a happy place between strongmen
power lifters bodybuilders crossfitters
where we could all come together under
one competition
the world deadlift champs and have it
out
and everybody accepted it all the all
the powerlifters
andy bolton the first man to pull a
thousand pounds
benny magnuson the current world record
holder in the deadlift at the time
they all came to the world deadlift
champs and we all agreed this was the
international way to sort of battle it
out for
who can deadlift the most and i'm afraid
this corona virus is no excuse to change
the international way of how a deadlift
should be should be
recorded does that mean eddie if i go in
and i take me i eat me witavix and i say
me prayers
and our deadly 550 next week
as unlikely as it might be am i now the
world record holder i mean it seems that
way
i mean i mean but that's i mean as funny
as that my sound brian that's
that's where that's where the wheel
could go now you're gonna get
thousands and thousands of people doing
world records on camera with the the mum
and dads
saying the down signal and basically
it's open pandora's box if everyone
accepts this world record
everyone can now set world records at
the home gym and record it and
and where who's did you test it like
seriously like
where do you draw the line this is the
big problem
for i mean we don't know what the
reaction is yet you know i
i personally think this shouldn't be
classed as a world record
and i think the majority you know let's
cut out the 16 year old fan girls that
watch game of thrones that are just
gobbling for off let's cut those people
out let's
stick with authority people in the
strongman world
the majority don't recognize this as a
world record and that and for me
if it's got a big cloud over it if it's
got like the slightest bit of negativity
i wouldn't do it i i would make sure it
was 100 i did see
uh your friend and former will strongest
man winner brian shaw
have a similar opinion who we all
respect him i think and
he said you know that's the problem it
this just is a never-ending
opening of people who can just claim
whatever now
because it was on a live stream why why
is it taking them four years to break
the record then
why is it just happening now that's
that's my main question is someone who
doesn't have the knowledge you do
yeah i mean well four has since i broke
the 500 kilo four has come out many
times and said he can pull 500 kilo
and he has attempted 501 kilo before as
well and he has failed before in a
competition
and as you say you know he's he's had
four years to get this done and it just
it just doesn't feel right that all of a
sudden there are no competitions
and it's got to be done you know i
understand that people peak in training
whatever else
but this this coronavirus you know the
america's already sort of breaking out
of this competitions
are going to start happening pretty soon
and i just don't i just don't think
there's any excuse for it to be
to be done in a home gym i mean let me
put this this way bro i mean we've just
watched for paul 501
in his home gym now i just want to point
out one thing and people
people can speculate all they want
there's a million things you can
speculate
but i witnessed four's dad weighing the
plates
for this attempt now and you know what i
mean i mean i think he was being watched
over but
and it was calibrated you know weights
and whatever and
the the the scale was calibrated
apparently but we all know
how easy it is to sort of rig these
things up now i'm not saying that
happened i am not saying that happened
but what i am saying is the speculation
is there
and that shouldn't there should be zero
speculation around a world record
absolutely zero now if let's rewind to
2016 when i pull 500 kilo
if my dad had to weighed those plates
regardless if they're calibrated
regardless if the scales calibrated
regardless if he's been watched if my
dad weighed those plates that i used on
that 500 kilo
would you accept that exactly uh
just to spin it round and turn it on you
because i have seen a few people
saying you know well what about eddie's
lift what about
what happened with his deadlift he
apparently had his own bar his own kit
what do you say to that because there's
a lot of people saying things like that
now
i think thor's fans are coming after you
now yeah
um so what are using my own bar and
kit that's what i've seen a few people
saying that and that the whole day was
around you and that
you know basically allowances were made
and it was all about you when you had
your own ball
yeah okay well i can i can answer that
that's not a problem um
i mean the bar was the same bar that
darren had the reason i had the bar
in advance and it wasn't the actual bar
i used on the day
darren sadler brought two bars
and i can't remember i can't remember
how exactly what happened but i believe
we were building up to this contest
and there was a uh ohio okie bar
or something like it was a ronnie crane
or something like oaky bar deadlift
being used
andy bolton had used this bar um for his
deadlift attempt i'd heard in the past
so had benny magnuson so i got one of
these bars
i acquired one of these bars because i
knew it was going to be used on the day
and i trained on the same bar that was
used on the day i'm not going to deny
that
but the bar that was used on the day was
then swapped i took the bar home that
was used on the day
and darren kept the one that was you
know used in in the gym
but there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that benny
magnusson trained on that same bar
because he trained in darren sadler's
gym
darren sadler decided just to bring you
up to date was the promoter the guy who
held this event he got all the equipment
and um
i think in 2015 when i pulled the world
record
463 i believe just from memory
i believe that the last lift i act i had
to ask for a wooden platform to be put
down because
the platform was just so badly damaged
and the mats were wrong so the mats were
were lined the wrong way so basically
these elico plates are so
solid and sort of crisp if you've got a
ridge
in the in the mats it doesn't roll very
well
so i said we had to put this board down
in 2015 for me to get the bar to roll
and do the deadlift attempt
and then in 2016 i remember it was about
two weeks before the show i rung darren
up and i said are you using the same
platform
he says yeah i said okay would you mind
if i brought two of my own mats
uh just to put down just so the deadlift
rolls nice because i don't want these
horrible ridges
in the in the platform that he had last
year he said yeah no problem
and all it was was two rubber mats and
you can go and look back on my training
footage
when i was training in the gym i trained
on the floor i didn't even have a
platform
and all i did was put two rubber mats
down on on the floor and that's why i
did lift it off and that's what i took
that's why i had delivered on the day to
make sure the deadlift was
rollable because you've got to envision
if these lines were stopping the
deadlift from rolling
and it's affecting people's deadlifting
you know we want the best chance to
people to give the best weights so um
those are the only two things i can
think of is i did use the same bar that
was used on the day
um because darren sadler had the same
bar and
i took mats with me that that sort of
on top of the platform and that that's
about all i can say they were his plates
so
they were aliko competition plates they
were his collars
um and obviously the platform itself was
his
you know everything all the underboard
and everything all the surrounding and
the
the knitting in and how it was made that
was all his
um so there's nothing really there that
can
be sort of give me an advantage as such
this this rivalry between you two it's
it's becoming the biggest thing ever
happened strong man i think that's fair
uh you are a celebrity
in in your own right and so is hey from
this game of thrones thing
as well as having all the credentials
physically
you're now taking this to the next level
we've got
world's strongest man 2017 world's
strongest man 2018
getting in a ring and fighting each
other you know just to put this into
perspective for people who don't
understand you know people talked about
andy ruiz being a big guy in there andy
ruiz was 280 pounds in his last fight
though it's 450 yeah you know
you know i you know [__] me this is
crazy
what made you think yeah i want to fight
him
what does this all stem from um well i
mean as you just say you know
by no means is for a small man you know
he's six foot nine is 450 pounds which
you know he's over 205 kilo i believe um
he's a giant of a man he's an absolute
giant of mine given the choice
i would never want to fight for it it'd
be it'd be a stupid life choice for
anyone on the planet to fight a man that
size
but this is why are you doing it then
yeah well this is more personal you know
it's not about the the contract it's not
about the money offer
it's not about this stupid deadlift feud
that we've got going on
i think it's the fact that he he accused
me of being a cheat
at will strongest man 2017 and he threw
all his accusations out there that
the referees were corrupt that the the
the the events were changed in my favor
that i knew the events in advance that
uh that the events were being changed
during the contest for my favor um there
was just so many so much [__] that
four came out with and
put this black cloud around my will
strongest man win
and at the time i didn't really think
anything of it i thought you know so
what i've got the trophy
it doesn't matter what he says but ever
since i've won my win
and especially straight after i won
every interview i did
was it wasn't about my win it was about
this controversy
it was um you know it wasn't like well
done for you in it was straight into it
like
four says he was robbed four says you've
won this illegitimately and it's like
you know i just won the will strongest
man and every single interview and tv
interviewer did
was based around defending myself and it
hurt me
it genuinely hurt me deep down it was
like i trained my whole life for this
one moment
and this guy just took it away or tried
to take it away from me because he
couldn't
take beating being beat by a better man
and that's why i want to fight him
because he put a black cloud over my
career and has done ever since and i
feel as though
for me i'm never going to get an apology
from four i know that and he's never
going to admit that i beat him fair and
square
but for me this is my way of putting
this to bed i feel like
i feel like if i can rip this guy's head
off in a boxing ring then
as soon as he said that as soon as this
contract landed on my table i was like
this is perfect this is absolutely
perfect this is my opportunity to get
one back on for
and like he did to me is to belittle him
and for the whole world to see
make him look an idiot because he tried
to do that to me it's funny because even
when you go back and watch the netflix
documentary done on you
even back then which was like five years
ago they highlight thor as your number
one rival and age in inability and
everything
i'm assuming this has been going on a
while now
can you take me back when you first met
thor and and what that was like and then
how the relationship has gone from that
moment almost
yeah um i mean i first met four back in
2012 i believe my very first
will strongest man and and we've
competed against each other numerous
times and we've hung out together you
know we've been out for meals he's
he's been around my house you know we've
had parties at my house in the past
i used to i used to really like four we
were great friends he used to be a great
guy
and i think there's a lot of people that
can back that up but i feel as though
i don't know what's changed about four
but he became this person that
he became a bit of a monster of like
everything had to be his way
and i think that really started it will
strongest man 2017
with with all the you know the the sort
of bad negativity around that
but i think honestly like up until that
point
me and four were fine we were completely
fine we got on we talked we respected
each other
i think there's always been that natural
rivalry there's always been that natural
competitiveness you know we get on but i
think deep down we're like
you know you you'd sit and have a meal
or you know share a bus ride before
you'd get on with him but afterwards
you'd be like you know
you are my competitor you know i want to
beat you so there's always been that
rivalry there
but there's always been respect and
i suppose that change that all changed
in 2017 when it when he when he called
me out
for trying to cheat the world's
strongest man with his
words um and then it's just going
downhill from there really you know
world's strongest man 2018 he brought up
a similar situation
where uh brian shaw did a deadlift and
he tried to get the result changed on
the deadlift you know sort of quarter
way into the final
um and again it's just a bad attitude of
when stuff's not going his way he
becomes this monster that
has to stomp his feet and i'll never
forget this brian
it will strongly expand 2017 the very
first discrepancy he brought up was
um the viking press so you know up until
this point everyone was hunky dory
everything was going smooth and then
four
said it was disallowed a rep on the
viking press and
after i'd gone and beaten him on this
event he then brought up the discrepancy
with the referees and the officials
and of the court you know they all
reviewed the footage they all happily
reviewed the footage and
they all said sorry for we all agree you
know
you should have got disallowed that one
rep even magnus for magnuson
said he should have got he would have
dislodged for the reps so he would have
been way worse off
but i'll never forget the image in my
head of
four standing over the head referee
going purple faced
clenching his fists and literally saying
to to
this head referee is that your decision
then is that your decision are you sure
you're making the decisions are you
making the right one and i just stood
there and i thought
[__] me this guy's an [__] like an
absolute [__]
and it's just it's progressed from there
it's got worse and worse before
i can only imagine the fact that you
guys used to hurt together he's been
your house like this is going to be
seriously personal before you get in
that ring they seem going to be
two competitors it's there's this is bad
blood like
i didn't realize it was that sort of bad
um
and i guess his his rise to fame from
game of thrones is
that must have played a party not in
that when you say the ego is growing and
he's
turning into the sky who can't be told
what to do did you do you think there's
a correlation between that fame
um i mean i'd like to say no but i think
it is i think
all that fame has gone to his head i
think you know he turns up at will's
strongest man
everyone turns up with a partner or a
physio
four will turn up with 30 people in blue
shirts and they will take over the arena
you know we'll be in the athlete tent
and i remember one year
i went to sit down in between events and
there wasn't a single chair
in the athlete tent because all four's
family was sat in the chairs
and i thought you know this is just
[__] ridiculous like the entourage
he takes around with him he walks around
with sunglasses on him doors
he's just got that very he's got that
very hollywood sort of
image about him that i hate and i think
all the other strong man hate as well
he's almost become
too big time you know he's he's above
everybody else
he won't hang around with any of of of
the other athletes in competition
he only hangs around with his you know
is his clan um
if you want to talk to four you have to
ask one of his clan you can't go to
indirect you know
it's it's genuinely ridiculous like how
bad is god
all right so you're you're gonna fight
this guy now and
i'm i don't envy your mate you've you've
got [__] balls on you there's no you
you talk about backing up your [__]
that is that you are
my [__] hero i [__] respect you
but
this is the thing um you're a beast in
your own right you know and he's gonna
have his hands full as well i'm pretty
sure he's gonna be thinking the same
thing
walking in there with you but do you
have any fighting experience from this
we've seen you hit pads before
um i mean boxing wise virtually zilch
you know i've done
i've done a i think i've done one
charity match in my life
against a reasonable boxer um and that
is pretty much it i've had one charity
i've had one charity boxing match
i've done little bits of boxing training
i could probably honestly say
i would say in my entire life i have
done less than 50
boxing sessions as in training sessions
that's the genuine truth
and i mean turn and fighting you know
not proud of my past but i i was a i
i was a a very sort of jack the lad in
my youth you know i would love a good
scrap
i would purposely go out on my way to
get into a scrap
and i'm not proud of that and i don't
wish that that to sort of be perceived
as my personality i'm not like that
but i did in my youth have a very bad
hard man image i did have that you know
i always thought
that and that's the way i was brought up
you know i was bro
in my area if you can knock that man out
if you can knock that kid out in the
same year as you
or if you can knock that kid out in the
other year at the other school if you
can knock that kid out the year above
you
then you were seen as the hard man you
were respected in my area where i'm from
we don't deal with things with words you
know straight away it's fists up
let's sort this out like men and that
that's how i've been brought up
and i suppose i mean having two brothers
as well two older brothers
and i can tell you now they can back me
up on this they beat the living [__] out
of me on a daily basis
on a daily basis i i was beaten black
and blue
broke my nose scars all over me so i'm
i'm not
you know i'm not no sort of stranger to
fighting
and then sort of getting when i was sort
of coming out of this hard man
image period um i set up my own door
company and i run the security in stoke
on trent quite a lot of security
and by jesus christ did i get in some
trouble
during that period you know and i've got
the scars to prove it
but in my opinion fighting on the street
doesn't mean anything
it really doesn't you know what does
that prove if anything it just proves
you're a bit of a
a bit of an idiot if i'm being honest
and i was a bit of an idiot happy to
admit that
to then transfer that into a boxing ring
it doesn't matter it really doesn't
matter
the only the only sort of thing i will
say is i can take a hit and i can give a
hit
but will that transfer over to boxing
probably yes
but i will have to forget all my fights
i've had for my entire life
all those little scraps all those little
you know beat me ups in the
in the nightclubs and on the street that
all goes out the window because boxing's
a different gate boxing
is a game of skill and this is where it
excites me
really as it's a whole new whole new
[__] it's a whole new thing to learn
and i'm quite looking forward to you
know getting in touch with coaches and
start learning the footwork and
the ducking and diving and whatever else
i'm going to enjoy it and i'm glad i'm
going to enjoy it because it's uh
i think i think you know we don't know
when this fight is going to happen
but it's going to be over a year i'd say
at least because you know i would want
12 months to train for this fight
i'm looking forward to it brian i know
that seems daft to say mate and you know
as big and nasty as four is as you say
you know you'd have to be an idiot get
in the ring before
i'm not an idiot mate i'm just a guy
that's got a grudge and i need to
[__] settle it with this guy
i need i need to [__] have a man to
man with this this man and [__] sort
it out
from the second you taught me about that
you were holding this fight i've
picked up this like confidence from you
like you've just got this inner belief
not not
not just about yourself but also about
him
i feel like you feel like you know when
it comes down to it he'll break before
you do
am i am i wrong there or am i on the
right lane no i think you're 100
there i just think i've got the mental
mental sort of approach a much better
mental approach than him
i'm gonna outwit him mentally and i'm
gonna outwit him physically as well this
the thing is with me brian is if i'm
confident then you're [__]
you are [__] if i'm confident in my
head i'm going to beat you that beat the
[__] out of you
then you should [__] run because
that's what i did the real strongest man
i'll never forget will strongest man
2017 i was the most
confident man on the planet you can look
on the interviews
i was i was doing this interview saying
i've already spent the prize money i've
already walked away the title
and the people behind the camera are
like this guy's [__] off his head
but i just had that confidence and i
know you know why i had that confidence
because i gave it every [__] ounce of
my life into training
and that's exactly what i'm going to do
with this fight i'm not going to take
i'm going to leave no stone unturned
i'm going to do everything in my power
to make sure i go in that ring
and [__] ridicule this prick there's
one thing about you like i'm
the more i've gotten to know you over
the years and stuff is um
you know i do think thought like you say
is a very gifted
athlete and it's it's it's almost been
handed to him whereas i feel like you've
had to work
a lot harder i think that would be fair
to say than he has and if there's one
thing that blew me away in the first
uh podcast that we did i came away
saying
this guy is the most determined person
i've ever met in my entire life and i've
interviewed many world champions and met
like fighters and all sorts you know i
mean but that determination you have is
going to carry you through this but
um if you were to sort of analyze thor a
little bit early on now
and you've spent plenty of time with
them is there any
weaknesses that you think he has that
you'll be looking to exploit
i mean that's a tough question to answer
you know because four is i mean four has
got to be
uh a sort of solid athlete he's got to
have that mental attitude
or else he wouldn't be will strongest
man but as you rightly say
he is almost a god's gift with the
genetics in that in that re
in that reign you know he has been he's
literally been handed the best genetics
on the planet
to be the will strongest man and to lift
the most weights you know
and i haven't got that i have not got
that but
what i have got is that mental approach
of it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how big you are how
hard you are how strong you are
and i know if i put my mind to it i will
beat you
and that's all that matters to me
there's going to be a lot of people
saying he is going to walk this i can
already
uh say in their twits and all that like
the guy's six foot nine
and in boxing you'd have to say he
is more built for it in theory than you
in terms of he's gonna have a massive
reach advantage
people are saying already oh if he gets
the job off that's it
he'll not get past that um what do you
say to those people
there's been many a fight in history
where the small man has won
and i feel as though just having a
height advantage
it won't be enough to keep me away i
mean look at mike tyson that guy's
destroyed so many people that were
bigger and stronger than him
he's living proof that if you get your
head down and train right
that you can do anything and i believe
i'm a big believer in that concept i am
gonna
i mean i i don't know how i'm gonna
attack this fight yet i'm not gonna give
you sort of
an analyst of how i'm gonna train for
this or how i think it's gonna go
um but you're right four has got the
reach he's got the height
and he's probably going to be taught to
stand tall and keep me off with a jab
but you know what we'll work around that
i think it's my job to sort of go away
think of
all attack methods all defense methods
and come in with no stone unturned
and so basically no matter what he does
in the ring i will have a response for
that
i do feel because obviously this is very
different to the youtube fights but i
think a lot of people are going to
be almost looking at it in a way of
non-boxers taking a box and they're
grouping the same
clearly this is different because you
and thor are two of the world's best
athletes
but your great strengths athletes and
boxing
is very different to that and and we've
seen criticism
already on twitter saying these guys are
going to gas out in two rounds it's
going to be a terrible fight
it's going to be awful um i don't i want
to put that to you as well mate like how
do you feel about people saying that
i've got no worries about that you know
as long as i've got a good amount of
time to train for this
i'll make sure i'm fit i'm already a fit
guy i i can i can swim and run and
cycle and whatever else for a long a lot
longer period than people think
and you know i've done my boxing
training i've done little bits
and trust me like i won't gas i will not
gas i will train hard enough i'll be
prepared for this
to go the three-minute rounds and and
even go the 12
how many rounds is it in boxing is it 12
or 14. people are going to clip that up
and post that on twitter i'll tell you
right now how many rounds is it in
boxing
first conversation from eddie hall jesus
i love it
no it is well i i very much doubt you
guys would be asking for 12 3s uh with
it being your first it's a pro fight i'm
assuming no head cards
yeah yeah eddie yeah eddie hearn will be
loving that
um so uh i guess
you know the youtube guys did six threes
and they fought
hard you know like the boys went at it
um
you know you're gonna have to transform
your body and i'm sure you're already
well aware of that uh you were a former
you know
champion swimmer so the gas tank has
been there before and i'm sure you can
get that there again
i'm assuming you're planning on shedding
the weight even more than you already
have
yeah again i i've got no clue as to what
i'm gonna
you know this is completely new to me
you know this is we would have been
talking about this for a week or so
it's completely new to me i don't know
what bodyweight i'm going to come in at
i really don't i don't know
i need to go away analyze everything
sort of think of an attack and and stick
with a plan basically
i mean of course you know at the minute
i'm 170 kilos so i'm about
top of my head that's like 27 and a bit
stone um
and i think to walk in the ring at this
weight would be a big mistake
you know i've got to drop a load of body
weight so i can go those three minute
rounds you know i actually put something
into it
um the other big thing is is what what
is four going to do because if he comes
in at over 400 pounds
i think that'll be a big mistake as well
but you know people could argue maybe he
could finish it within
30 seconds a minute you know i think
this is what it's exciting me
thinking about all these me this is like
superheroes going at it i think that
a few people who are writing it off i'm
like you guys do not understand
like people get excited for tyson fury
uh and anthony joshua you two make those
guys look like children
like this is gonna be insane you know
what i mean
um if there's one thing i've learned
from the youtube lads who i've sat and
watched and we've had all these chats of
they've gone in there and learnt it from
scratch like yourself
it's the ones who surround themselves
with the most knowledgeable boxing
people
are the ones who usually win you know
the ones who are getting the best
training
from people who understand boxing and
and dedicate themselves 110 percent
and and don't take time off and don't
chance it like you won't i know but um
as a mate i think it's imperative that
you find the right people
to to learn from like yeah and i think
that's going to be four's approach as
well you know
he's a professional he's he's been a
professional in in his a game the same
as me
so i think both of us are gonna go into
this with that same mentality
we're gonna leave no stone unturned
we're gonna sort out out the best best
people
we're going to be doing the best
recovery methods you know we're going to
get the best of everything so there's
going to be
i i can always guarantee four is going
to go as hard as this as he did at
will's strongest man and
the 501 attempt he's going to be gunning
for this because
you know what he's got a lot more to
lose than i have he genuinely has you
know the guy's six foot nine is he's a
huge man
to get beat up by a six foot two and a
half guy
and i don't think he'd ever live that
down so he's going to be training
just as hard as this as i am weirdly for
once you're david not
not goliath here you know i kind of feel
like there is going to be pressure on
this guy isn't there
and the entourage and all of that in the
hollywood thing is
for grabs there but this the difference
with this is you know
the the loser doesn't get a silver medal
in and stands a little bit below each
other on a podium
he's on the floor some potentially and i
think with how big you guys are
it stands to reason that one of you is
getting chinned um
have you sort of played around with that
possibility in your head and you know
thought well can i handle this as a man
because many can't ego wise
you know what i haven't even thought
about losing brian it's not in my
mentality
to think about coming second or or being
that guy laying on the floor
i i've come in with a plan a and that's
what i'm sticking with
if if the worst were to happen and i
were to get laid out
then you know what mate it's like like i
did with real strongest man
i went against the odds and eventually i
came out on top
so and this is exactly what i'll do with
this if and it's a big if
i do go in and i get flawed there will
be a there will be a rematch i'm telling
you now
and if he gets if he gets forward there
will be a rematch because i don't think
we can settle this with one fight
there's going to be a few
yeah i i like the way you're thinking
there because um you know
that gives you guys both an opportunity
to put things right make the alterations
that you'd want to make and
they did the same thing with the the
lads ksi and logan paul
and ultimately it'd be great for you too
to make a [__] ton of money
the possible damages i know you're no
[__] stranger to being
you know in danger because of the [__]
you i mean that 500 kilograms was
terrifying enough
your family you know for example how
everyone's seen how close you are with
your wife how is she taking the fact
that you're going to go and fight this
guy is everyone else okay with it no
they hate it they absolutely hate it
but that's life you know my wife wants
me to stay at home and be safe and look
after her and
you know be the bread woman and and
that's what that's what all wives want
no but nobody's wife wants the husband
to go out there
and risk the life for for a bit of cash
you know
and i guess that for me
if that were the case i would say yeah
you know what baby you're right i'm not
gonna do it this is this is a big
mistake
but this is more than just money this is
personal this is
me settling a score with an old enemy
that needs settling and and my family
have got to
got to accept that my mum and dad are
getting really upset about it my wife's
getting upset about it
i don't know what the rest of my family
and friends think but no one will change
my mind and they know that so
then they know like i did for the
world's strongest man i was getting
close to death
chasing that will strongest man tile i
had a few health scares and i was told
by a lot of family members to
back off and you know live a long life
it's not worth your life but
no one could stop me brian i wanted that
title more than anything and i was
willing to risk my life for it and
i feel like the same as this really is
no one's going to tell me any different
i'm willing to risk my life to to prove
a point you know
i respect that this is it's a it's a
good old-fashioned straightener
in in many respects but one thing that
you did say to me after the world
strongest man win
was that's it no more competing no more
they say i'm going to be a good family
man
and three years later you're like i'm
fighting the thor
you passed that circus i'm like [__]
helmet
um are you missing that training and
that competitive edge
because you you know that the animals
inside you know what i mean you got to
let it out i guess 100 i am mate 100 i
am
i'm i'm just glad i'm so glad i walked
away from strongman people
have given me no end of [__] saying i'm
scared to lose my title i'm scared to
return
i'm not scared my plan a was to win the
will strongest man and get out that's
always been my plan
and i stuck to it i was 433 pounds when
i won the will strongest man
i don't give a [__] what anyone says
jesus for my height
i was the biggest man on the [__]
planet that day the biggest man
and if you put that in the stats i was
at most at risk to have a heart attack
the most at risk to have a stroke liver
kidney failure
i was if there's a table i was [__]
in the sky
i was well above and beyond so that's
why i had to
i had to walk away from strongman
because i am not six foot nine i am not
a natural giant i cannot be
450 pounds somewhat naturally
you know i can't hold that weight as
well as four can so that's my reason for
walking away so yes
you are completely right for this excuse
to sort of get back in the training
world and get my head down and get my
eye back on the ball so to say i'm
[__] thriving brian i cannot wait to
get going with this training
because that's what i'm that's what i'm
used to mate that's my outlet
i've always i've always suffered with
depression mental health
and training has always been my outlet
it still is now
that's why i'm so big and strong now i'm
not as big as strong as i was but
it's my way of keeping straight and now
it's my way of keeping the demons away
and i think this fight with four
is gonna seal those demons up
definitely it's gonna help it's gonna
help my life in more ways than one
yeah i mean i'm when you say it like
that i you know i can't i can't disagree
with your reasons behind it
um and for those who did say you were
scared like
i think you've proved that you're not
scared because because this boxing match
is uh you know would scare a lot more
people than picking a way off in a
competition you know what i mean
you asked you ask every man on the
planet do you want to step in the ring
with four for a million quid
i mean some idiots might say yes but i
think the majority would just fold and
be like no it's not worth my life
yeah and not after that 501 kilogram
deadlift especially like
um and and uh one thing i'd like to get
on
is your weight loss because obviously
this is going to continue now in
and i remember after world strongest
mind you said i'm going to shred up
i'm going to show people like i'm not
just this because they were having to go
to you online the big fat guy comments
and all of that
then just as you said you would you turn
around
you've got abs and you're doing cardio
and stuff like that
um i i've wanted to know this how did
you make that happen
um well you're completely right mate it
was more of a point of
proving i could you know ever my whole
career pretty much i've been called a
fat bastard
which it's not it's not bothered me when
i was in competition
but as soon as i won the world's
strongest man i was like you know what
there's some horrible people out there
that
love to body shame and you know
everyone said i was this big massive fat
cephalic bastard
but i knew i was a big baller muscle you
know it was it was functional
i had a huge belly but i'm telling you
now you couldn't pinch an
ounce of fat on my stomach it was solid
and
i suppose i just wanted to prove a point
to strip up and
prove that i wasn't this you know
grotesque sort of fat mess
winning the world's strongest man there
was there was an athlete a good-looking
bloke underneath and i've done that i've
proved it
and i proved it can be done um
and now you know what i've put a bit of
weight back on i've been very up and
down i've been
i've been part of a tv show the
strongest man in history so i've had i
had to put weight back on for that show
to sort of
keep up with the other boys but in all
honest with you brian
i enjoyed i enjoy being big and strong
i enjoy being a big guy i didn't give a
[__] if people call me a fat bastard
you know what i enjoy i'm happy with my
life i've got a great life
i've got an amazing wife and kids you
know a nice place to live
um but no no no no worries i'm happy
so for people to body shame like you get
on with your lives i'm not really
bothered but i've proved it can be done
yeah you uh i'm assuming you went on a
diet for that was there was there
anything special that you did
like sorry i completely deferred the
question um
yeah it's kind of i i i basically cut
carbs out for a good year
i just ate nothing but meat and you know
and sort of
dairy and vegetables for a complete year
i did lots of cardio a lot
carried on with my weight training and
the weight fell off me
i i think i mean bear in mind i was 433
pounds in my prime
um the the sort of most recent where i
did a transformation i dropped down to
350 pounds
so i lost well 80 pounds is that 83
pounds
yeah in a couple of years uh for those
who don't know that's like five
over five stone yeah yeah it's a lot of
weight
it's a lot of weight that's nearly a
person lost you know your body's going
to change a lot now because obviously
boxing is just so
different everything you're you're going
to be doing you're going to look
softer as they say in bodybuilding you
know you're not you're probably going to
look more like a big rugby player by the
time you get in there i would imagine
yeah i mean i mean look at
andy um andy ruiz ruiz he he got
i mean he got absolutely blasted when he
beat aj but
you know and then and then he became the
poster boy for [__] snickers
i was gutted when he got back in there
because i had money on him to win that
night even though i wanted aj to win i
had money on him
and he was i was like me you're just too
fat now this is taking the piss yeah
how many snickers have you had uh like
when i'm in better shape than the
heavyweight trap of the world we know
he's [__]
do you know what i mean but yeah one
thing i want to ask you about well
before before you go because i know you
haven't got along me um you're a
businessman now
you've really changed the game for
strong man
and uh this whole thing is now you're
leveling it up again is
where where is this going for you
where's the empire that you're building
headed because i've been fascinated by
what the moves you've made
um i mean my plan from day one was to
win the world's strongest man and then
capitalize on the back of that
which i've been doing you know i'm
riding that wave hard
i've had two very successful tv shows
one of them
i was meant to be filming season two
right now um but obviously it's been
postponed um i've set up many
many little businesses for a couple in
stoke i've set some international ones
up
um i think one of the main things is is
getting into the sort of movie side of
things doing a lot of
wheeling and dealing with directors and
producers and and
doing some good deals um the second
documentaries in the making
in conjunction with arnold
schwarzenegger so that's you know that's
a big production
and then i think the final and most
impressive thing is for me and it's such
like i can smile from ear to ear saying
this
i am business partners with arnold
schwarzenegger i am bringing the arnold
classic uk
to the united kingdom uh for everyone to
come and meet arnold schwarzenegger and
you know what to say that to say those
words from a childhood hero to
to being a five-year-old kid sitting
there with my jaw on the floor
watching the terminator kick the [__]
out of 20 outlaws
and you know butt naked and then ride
off on a new motorbike to now
being a business partner of arnold
schwarzenegger it's honestly brian like
i have to pinch myself sometimes mate
because it's mental it's it is surreal
and there's a lot more to come mate
there's a lot more big deals to be done
and yeah you know i take i take great
pride in
riding that wave on the back of will's
strongest man and i will say this
and and and i think this goes for every
will strongest man including four
is that you've got to be somewhat clever
you know you've got to have your wits
about you've got to have a good grasp on
life you've got to have a good grasp on
business
and if you haven't then you're going to
be one of those guys that wins the will
strongest man and then goes back to a
normal job
and there's been plenty of those guys
and you know i'm not going to be one of
those people now
you said that on the first documentary
about you you know you don't want to be
that guy who
could have won world's strongest man
book didn't have the bottle of quit his
job and
you're like i'm going for it and it's
it's fantastic say five years later
uh how it's going for you and while
we're on it do you think you could get
arnold schwarzenegger on the true johnny
podcast by any chance
oh you know what mate i i will um
put a word in [__] hell i will i will
talk to you behind the scenes i will i
will do something
for you yes all right legend legend i'll
be i couldn't help it i couldn't resist
that
that's fine no i'd be exactly the same
he's a legend
absolutely he's a legend man i remember
uh terminator 2 and just thinking i
don't know i'm all in on this like i
have the action fingers
everything um
but um so lastly uh locked down
you're living uh like we all off and
can't leave the house all this [__]
uh how are you coping mentally because
you're you're an outdoorsy kind of guy
um it was tough at first i think the
first um
well let's rewind a little bit i was out
in australia when all this kicked off so
i was out there with my dad and brother
doing a little tour of sydney and
melbourne
and it all kicked off and we had to get
emergency flights back
to the uk and literally i think three
days after i arrived back the the uk
went into lockdown
and it was tough man i think everybody
in the country was literally heading
hands like
what the [__] is going on here um it was
really hard to sort of get acclimatized
with
being in the house 24 7. you know me and
the wife had some
horrendous fallouts
but like i just i've just very quickly
realized that i need to get into a
regime so straight away within
within a week i you know i've got my
whiteboard out i'm writing out
uh sort of strength programs and
whatever else and i'm
honestly brian every single day i have
trained for pretty much three to four to
five hours pretty much
i've had i've had my rest days but just
the regime just keeping busy
doing my training every day and then as
soon as i've done my training i'm
i'm on me emails i'm doing presenting
work for tv channels and
other youtube channels and stuff like
that and people think
it's hilarious really people think i'm
just sat on my hands with nothing to do
you know i'm getting so many but
i think you're the same you're getting
so many requests from people thinking
you're doing [__] all
it's quite hilarious actually whereas
actual fact honestly i
like i feel now busier than i was when
we weren't locked down it's nuts
made absolutely the same like i've never
had this much work in my life coming my
way you know
mad honestly mate i'll i'll let you go
now but i just want to wish you the best
of luck for everything
i'm fully confident in you because i
know what's up
in your head i know you're going to make
sure that you get everything done
so when you go on that ring oh it's on
then you're going to smash up the bit
it's on it and this is a message for
four
just want to see me well actually you're
not my mate you're a prick
um you started this
you know you generally started this will
strongest man 2017. you called me a
cheat
forget the deadlift forget our feud you
called me a cheat
and i'm going to correct that by
knocking you the [__] out
i [__] love it i [__] love it oh
my god
this is this world's colliding here it's
going to be amazing um
if everyone hasn't already you can
subscribe to eddie's youtube channel
he's just hit a million subscribers he's
absolutely killing it
on that channel right now and uh yeah
hit the like button
stay subscribed the true jordy youtube
channel thanks for watching
and we'll see yous later